bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de platon et de
l'accord sont
alors pourquoi ce thème de la corruption
est bien parce qu'il y avait chez platon
une vision de la nature humaine et plus
généralement
une vision de l'univers et de ses lois
nous permettre de comprendre en quoi les
êtres humains vous
moi
nous tous
serions fondamentalement corrompus
alors bien sûr en disant ça g ce que
beaucoup parmi vous vont soit ne pas
être d'accord
un vouloir en savoir plus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire nous serions
tous corrompus
est ce que ce n'est pas une manière un
peu
edit yves
jugez l'être humain
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu facile
un peu convenue
de dire que l'être humain est un être
corrompu
l'ancien testament
depuis la genèse
le péché d'adam et eve a soumis sion
d'adam et eve à la tentation du fruit
défendu
l'expulsion du jardin d'éden
ce serait la marque de notre corruption
c'est à dire de notre éloignement
vis-à-vis de dieu et du bien
dès qu'on retrouve dans toute l'histoire
de la pensée occidentale
on la retrouve chez pascal au xviie
siècle
pascal qui reprochait à l'homme sa
concupiscence
autrement dit son penchant à l'envi
son penchant au vice
obs partager ce point de vue quand il
disait que l'homme est un loup pour
l'homme
que la seule chose qui motive l'être
humain
c'est la satisfaction de ses désirs
égoïstes
et notamment de ses désirs matériels
et l'allemand le même constat que feront
les philosophes libéraux au xviiie
siècle
on peut penser par exemple à elle laisse
us
avait une phrase absolument lumineuse
sur la question il disait
si l'univers physique est soumis à la
loi du mouvement
univers moral est régie par la loi de
l'intérêt
c'est une formule radical
mais c'est une formule qui a le mérite
de la clarté
à savoir que pour les libéraux
il ne faut pas chercher à rendre les
hommes vertueux
parce que ça ça ne marche pas
il ne faut pas
rendre les hommes vertueux il ne faut
pas chercher à corriger leurs vices il
faut au contraire
reconnaître novice il faut reconnaître
notre nature corrompue
et essayer de faire avec
et faire ça voulait dire pour les
libéraux trouvé le moyen de réguler
l'égoïsme des hommes
trouver un moyen de satisfaire cet
égoïsme
sans que cela ne mette à mal la
coexistence entre les membres de la
société
ce moyen
ras le marché
donc vous voyez que la corruption
l'homme l'idée que l'homme est un être
fondamentalement à vide égoïste
c'est une vieille histoire
et quel que soit notre opinion sur la
question
on qui se pose c'est
bien cette idée
d'où vient dès que l'être humain
ray corrompu
et bien ce qu'on va huismes ses comptes
chez platon c'est-à-dire au vème siècle
avant jésus-christ
la corruption est non seulement une
propriété des hommes
calé
propriété de notre univers lui même
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire que la
corruption serait une propriété de notre
univers
tiens c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir aujourd'hui
alors pour commencer la première chose à
élucider
c'est qu'est ce qu'on appelle la
corruption
au sens courant du terme la corruption
fait d'aller à l'encontre de ses
principes
contre de ses valeurs ses valeurs
morales
en échange d'un profit matériel
on dira qu une perte des corrompus quand
par exemple elle acceptera de mentir
contre de l'argent
quand elle acceptera de fermer les yeux
contre des avantages
quand elle fera usage de son autorité
pour obtenir certaines faveurs
tu l'essence de la corruption n'est pas
simplement d'agir contre la morale
c'était pas simplement d'être malhonnête
c'est d'être malhonnête en échange d'une
récompense matérielle
pourquoi cette précision est importante
parce qu'en fin de compte le malhonnête
qui ne reçoit pas davantage en échange
de sa malhonnêteté
le malhonnête bénévoles si je puis dire
et bien finalement il est moins
corrompus que celui qui l'est par
intérêt
le malhonnête bénévoles
il n'a pas besoin d'être rétribué pour
sa malhonnêteté
il n'attend pas une récompense pour être
malhonnête
ils les spontanément
d'autres mon le malhonnête bénévoles est
beaucoup plus en accord avec lui-même
il est fidèle même
alors que le malhonnête corrompu le
malhonnête qu'on peut soudoyer
c'est une motivation extérieur
qui influencent son comportement
la motivation
terré
l'individu corrompus
lui qui fait par intérêt ce qui ne
ferait pas sans cet intérêt
alors il ya des tas de choses qu'on
ferait par intérêt et non pas par
passion par conviction
se lever le matin pour aller travailler
pour moins 90% des gens
ce n'est pas par plaisir
ce n'est pas par naughty vation
intérieure qu'on accepte de faire un
boulot usant
c'est par une motivation extérieur
gagner de l'argent pour remplir le frigo
mais ce qu'on peut
sont
pas vraiment
c'est d'abord une nécessité
donc si nécessité c'est être corrompu
nous sommes tous corrompus
et tous rappelons ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure être corrompu c'est accepter de
faire quelque chose dont on sait que
cela va à l'encontre de la morale
c'est accepter de faire quelque chose
dont on sait que ce n'est pas juste
l' arbitre de foot corrompus
le juge corrompu
l'homme politique corrompue
non seulement la corruption on n'est pas
pour eux une nécessité vitale
et surtout ils savent très bien
fondée pas juste
ils savent très bien qu aucun système
moral ne peut venir à leur secours pour
justifier leur corruption
à part peut-être le nihilisme
qui fait que la corruption fait partie
des choses qui sont généralement assez
mal perçu
quoi bien parce que si on peut acheter
la conscience de quelqu'un
si on peut téléguidé son comportement
par de l'argent et bien ça veut dire que
la personne
renonce à sa conscience
et si elle renonce à sa conscience elle
perd quelque chose d'essentiel à son
statut d'être humain
ce qui caractérise l'être humain c'est
sa possibilité de dire non
sa possibilité de placer des valeurs au
dessus de l'intérêt matériel
autrement dit de ne pas être l'esclave
de l'intérêt
q c'est l'individu une dont la
conscience est monnayable
c'est l'individu dont la conscience et à
chaud table
cette à l'individu corrompu on achète le
silence de sa conscience
le bâillonnement 2 conscience
et si on peut acheter le bâillonnement
de sa conscience si on peut faire en
sorte que la conscience de la personne
se soumettent aux désirs du notre
conscience
bien anthropologiquement
ça signifie que la personne
n'en est plus totalement une
ça veut dire que l'individu
n'est plus son propre maître
mais qu'il devient le serviteur d'une
conscience extérieur
les moyens matériels de se l'approprier
c'est ce que les gueux l'appelait la
conscience servile
la conscience qui renonce à sa
souveraineté
et qui se donnent au plus offrant
emmanuel kant disait que le sens moral
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre
une personne et une chose
si vous lancez une pierre dans l'eau
qu'un moyen de dévier de la trajectoire
que vous lui aurez impulser
parce qu'elle n'a pas de conscience
parce qu'elle n'a pas de volonté issus
de sa conscience
donc elle n'a pas la possibilité
hermine est elle-même sa trajectoire
sun
vous ne pouvez pas long vous voulez
vous ne pouvez pas lui faire ce que vous
voulez
seulement un corps
elle est une conscience
et parce qu'elle est une ce ces axes
armin et par sa volonté
on peut pas
sonne comme on manipule une chose
parce qu'un être humain n'est pas une
marionnette
autrement dit parce que l'être humain a
la capacité de refuser qu'on dispose de
lui
et c'est justement pour ça que le seul
moyen de manipuler une personne
manipuler au sens littéral comme on dit
qu'on manipule un objet
seul moyen de manipuler une personne
c'est de manipuler sa volonté
c'est de convertir sa volonté
si vous trouvez lyon d'influencer la
volonté de l'individu
vous n'avez plus besoin de le
contraindre
vous avez simplement à lui proposer
une offre qu'il ne peut pas refuser
une offre qui va peser dans la balance
plus lourd que sa conscience morale
et dès lors que vous vous êtes approprié
sa volonté vous vous êtes approprié
les manettes de son comportement
vous êtes approprié
la télécommande de ces actions
est alors la personne devient
littéralement
votre chose
la corruption
c'est ce qui fait sohn accepte de
devenir une chose
qu'elle choisit de devenir une chose
autres on dit qu'elle use de sa liberté
pour vendre sa liberté
seul un être libre peut être dit
corrompu
parce que seul un être libre à la
possibilité de monnayer sa conscience
et donc de choisir librement de renoncer
à ses principes
et si la corruption est aussi mal vu si
elle est souvent perçu comme relevant de
la laideur morale je mets des guillemets
c'est précisément parce qu'elle consiste
dans un abandon d'une partie de notre
humanité
à savoir notre conscience et la liberté
qui en découlent
on a vu dans l'épisode sur sartre l
amour que ce qu'on cherche à travers
l'amour c'est s'approprier l'autre comme
être libre
passe appropriez l'autre comme un
automate
pas à s'approprier l'autre comme un
petit toutou
parce qu'alors l'autre n'est plus
aimable
étant donné qu'il perd symboliquement
son statut de personne
c'est à dire son statut de conscience
souveraine
on ne peut pas aimer celui qui renonce à
sa liberté
parce qu'on ne peut pas aimer une chose
donc si on hall de laideur morale à
propos de la corruption
si on est aussi sévère dans notre
jugement
c'est pour ça
parlait de laideur morale
parler de pratiques salle
voyez tout ce champ lexical de la
dégradation
c'est la dégradation de l'être humain
qui n'accorde pas de valeur
à son indépendance moral
de l'être humain pour qui
dignité à un prix
et qui ce faisant consent à sa
marchandisation
donc la corruption le ce n'est pas tant
le fait de commettre des actes
considérés comme illégitimes
parce qu'après tout
juge de ce qui est légitime
la corde c'est le fait d'aller à
l'encontre de notre conscience à
l'encontre notre propre conception du
légitime
parce qu'une autre conscience a le
pouvoir d'acheter notre consentement
on sait le fait de dire à sa propre
conscience
toi
c'est le fait de dire à sa conscience
arrête de faire bruit
tu me dérange
parce que lorsque je t'entends je ne
peux pas ce que je veux
je ne peux pas oublier mes principes
comme je le veux
la corruption c'est lorsque la
conscience choisis librement
de ne plus être une conscience libre
donc ça c'était pour le sens courant du
mot corruption
la corruption au sens moral
mais ce qu'il faut remarquer c'est que
la corruption
ce n'est pas une notion qui concerne
uniquement la morale
c'est aussi une notion qu'on trouve en
physique
et vous allez voir qu'il ya peut-être
justement un lien à faire entre les deux
au sens physique la corruption c'est la
détérioration progressive de la matière
alors dans le langage courant on
n'emploie pas vraiment le mot corruption
dans ce sens
on parle plutôt d'usure
mesure pour un objet on parle de
vieillissement pour un corps
mais dans les deux cas
psion au sens où il s'agit d'une
dégradation de la matière
et d'ailleurs remarquer une chose
c'est que quand on parle d'un fruit qui
se corrompt on dit que le fruit pourri
or dans langage familier
un pourri c'est une paire on put
donc entre la corruption physique et la
corruption morale il y à bien un rapport
rapport d'analogie
si la corruption est une dégradation
physique c'est la dégradation du corps
et la corruption morale c'est la
dégradation de la conscience
donc c'est la même chose
domaines différents
au corps et à l'esprit
et on peut prolonger l'analogie un corps
jeune c'est un corps qui n'a pas encore
entamé son processus de dégradation
de même qu'une conscience jeunes c'est
une conscience naïve
une conscience pure et innocente
c'est une ce qui n'a pas et usé par
l'expérience de la vie
d'ailleurs c'est souvent qu'on le conte
est le plus idéaliste qu'on a les
aspirations les plus pures
parce qu'on n'a pas encore vraiment vécu
parce qu'on est inconscient de ce que la
vie est capable de mettre comme épreuve
sur notre chemin
et plus la conscience se frotte au monde
et à ses difficultés
plus elle se frotte à la souffrance au
mensonge à la trahison
plus elle perd de son innocence
plus la pause ce acquiert de
l'expérience
plus la pureté fini par nous apparaître
comme de la naïveté
et la corruption comme du réalisme
une conscience expérimentés c'est une
con qui a renoncé à l'idéal
parce qu'elle sait que le monde n'est
pas idéal
accroché à cet idéal
s'accrocher à la pureté
c'est le meilleur moyen d'être déçus
et larmes j'aimerais vous faire
chose de très important pour la suite
qui est que depuis tout
les mots qu'on utilise
corruption idéal pureté
bien il se trouve sont les mots de la
métaphysique de platon
or pour platon la corruption se résume
pas seulement à la corruption morale
elle ne se résume pas non plus à la
corruption de la matière
elle est tout ça à la fois
et plus encore
pour le dire simplement chez plat la
corruption
est une
notre monde
on va essayer d'expliquer maintenant
pour platon le monde que nous habitons
le monde terrestre ce qu'il appelle le
monde sensible c'est corrompu
pag auront pu au sens où les êtres
humains seraient tous des vendus
corrompus au sens
soumis à la loi métaphysique de la
dégradation
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
bien ça veut dire que tout ce qui existe
est voué à disparaître
tout ce qui existe est voué à la
décomposition
donc ça concerne aussi bien les objets
inanimés
les objets fabriqués par l'homme cette
table cette chaise ce stylo
mais ça concerne aussi bien entendu les
êtres vivants
tout ce qui vit finira par mourir
tout ce qui existe finira par
disparaître
de ce pont du las
des locataires de l'existence
comme le disait heidegger
nous sommes des aides vers la mort
nous sommes des êtres qui avons
conscience
on s'est inexorablement vers l'heure de
notre disparition
et ce n'est pas une affaire
on s'en remettra très bien
la mort c'est d'abord le problème des
vivants
donc tout ce qui vit est condamné à
mourir
tout ce qui fleurit et condamnait affalé
d'ailleurs c'est amusant qu'on utilise
le mot mortels comme un synonyme du mot
vivant
un vivant c'est un mortel
dont le départ
mais en réalité ce paradoxe n'en est
plus un dès lors qu'on comprend que tout
ce qui vit est par essence voué à mourir
naître c'est partir vers la mort
et là où nous a tendance à voir la
naissance et la mort comme des termes
qui s'excluent il faut au contraire y
voir deux réalités indissociables
les deux faces de la même pièce
la naissance moore sont constitutives
d'une seule et même réalité qui est la
vie
alors explique ont un peu ça
d'un point de vue purement individuel
notre vim c'est tout ce que nous avons
et notre mort
c'est la mort de tout ce que nous avons
en ce sens chaque mort est une monde
mais à l'échelle de l'humanité à
l'échelle du vivant la mort n'est pas
une fin
la mort est r la condition du
recommencement
elle est la condition de la perpétuation
du cycle générationnel
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
on peut dire ça d'abord ce que la vie se
nourrit de la mort
il y à un poème de baudelaire qui décrit
assez bien ça
son poème une charogne
rogne baudelaire décrit la dépouille
d'un animal
il montre que sur cette dépouille
la vie fourmille
il nous parle de noir bataillon de
l'arve
il nous parle de mouches qui bourdonnent
et qui gros yeux
on est dans le champ lexical de la vie
or qui pourrit ce sont des insectes qui
se nourrissent
ce sont des mammifères qui se
nourrissent
des chiens et loups
la charogne c'est le repas des chats
régnard
donc la mort nourrit la vie
et en se décomposant rose quant à la
terre
rogne nourrira la terre
une terre qui a à de fruits et de
végétaux qui serviront à nourrir les
vivants
donc c'est d'abord ce sens que la mort
est utile à la vie
que la mort est un élément de la vie
la deuxième raison pour laquelle la mort
est utile à la vie c'est parce que si
l'amant n'existait pas
nous n'aurions aucune raison de nous
reproduire
la faune
reproductrices n'aurait pas lieu d'être
parce que se reproduire c'est se
perpétuer au delà des limites
temporelles de sa propre vie
re produire
ces se produire à nouveau
c'est se répliquer à l'extérieur de soi
en plus jeunes
alors oui l'enfant à sa propre vie il a
sa propre personnalité
extension de ses parents on l'accord
parent
l'enfant
c'est la suite de soi même
on sait l'être pour lequel on est prêt à
sacrifier sa vie
ces lettres dont la vie vaut davantage
que la nôtre
parce que c'est la version nous-mêmes
qui va mourir après nous
et qui n'a pas encore été corrompus
donc même si leur si on n'est pas à
proprement parler une duplication
elle est un prolongement temporel de soi
une survivance de soi
la logique jeu schnell voulant que le
parent quitte ce monde avant son enfant
on a deux manières de laisser une trace
de notre passage sur terre
en produisant
reproduisant
en créant
en pro créant
les deux pouvant évidemment se combiner
dans le cas de la reproduction 11
tu d'une génération
après la mort on continue d'exister dans
la mémoire et dans le coeur de sa
progéniture
à partir de la deuxième génération la
génération des petits enfants
on existe encore après sa mort
mais de manière moins intense
les parents sont deux mais les grands
parents sont quatre
et
si on aime ses grands-parents et qu'on
se souvient d'eux
la flamme de leur mémoire temps être
moins vive
troisième génération arrière petits
enfants
la mémoire commence à décliner
on voit de vieux portraits en noir et
blanc
on discerne une vague ressemblance
physique avec même
le nez les yeux
mais ça s'arrête là
et on a beau savoir qu on n'existerait
pas sans ses huit arrières grands
parents
on a beau savoir que nous sommes la
trace vivante de leur passage sur terre
le fait est qu'on entretient plus la
flamme de leur mémoire
la deuxième de laisser une trace de
notre passage
c'est la création
création au sens large
création d'une oeuvre artistique
scientifique
ural
aussi création
de l'histoire
les faits d'armes
les exploits
les règnes
de qui se souvient après des centaines
voire des milliers d'années
des héros
des empereurs
et guerrier
de ceux pour qui justement
mourir au combat était un moyen de
continuer à vivre dans l'esprit de la
postérité
parce qu ainsi le monde retiendrai leur
nom
s'inspirerait deux des siècles après
leur mort
si les spartiates était heureux de
sacrifier leur vie au combat
parce qu'ils savaient qu'ils aient
changé leur vie
contre leur immortalité
autre paradoxe
mourir au conte ce n'était pas mourir
c'était au contraire se garantir une
immortalité dans l'histoire
donc pour revenir à ce qu'on dise m la
mort n'est pas un accident de la vie
la mort est la deuxième extrémité de la
vie
essence et la première extrémité de la
et c'est cette polarité de la naissance
et de la mort
qui constitue le cycle de la vie c'est à
dire le cycle de la génération et de la
corruption
et quand je peux deux générations et de
pas ses mots au hasard
j'emploie ces mots parce que ce sont
ceux qu'utilise aristote
disciple de platon
traité qui s'appelle précisément de la
génération et de la corruption
lequel aristote montre bien en quoi
notre monde terrestre et d'intégrales
mans soumis à cette loi
donc tout ce qui existe à un
commencement et une fin et la corruption
ce n'est rien d'autre que la lente
évolution de toute chose qui commence
vers sa fin
et
bien laisser sa place aux nouveaux venus
il faut bien que la mort face de la
place pour la vie
et donc là il ya une notion sur laquelle
on va devoir s'arrêter qui est la notion
de cycle
qu'est ce qu'un cycle un cycle c'est un
mouvement circulaire qui nous fait
passer d'un point a à ce même point a
c'est à dire que c'est un mouvement qui
fait coïncider les extrémités
parcourir un cycle c'est parcourir un
cercle
et si vous placez un point sur un cercle
l'autre extrémité de ce cercle c'est ce
même point
c'est ce même point mais après avoir
effectué le tour du cercle
donc parcourir un cycle c'est parcourir
un trajet qui nous ramène à la fois au
point d'arrivée et au point de départ
en ce sens le cycle héberge la dualité
donc la totalité
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe entre deux
lever du soleil
il se passe un tour complet du soleil
dans l'horizon
il se passe ce zénith un crépuscule
une nuit et un retour à l'aube
donc durant un cycle du soleil le ciel
passe par toutes les teintes
et toutes ces teintes manifeste la
totalité des positions du soleil
un cycle égale un parcours de la
totalité
ce que signifie la notion de cycle il
faut ajouter que le cycle a besoin du
temps
ce qui fait
soumis à la loi des cycles à la loi de
l'alternance des opposés
c'est que notre monde physique et 2 sur
temporel
et donc en ce sens le temps c'est la
force qui pousse toute chose à rejoindre
son extrémité
c'est à dire à faire coïncider le point
de départ et le point d'arrivée
donc le temps c'est une machine à
déployer la totalité
et c'est en cela que comprendre la
notion de cycle c'est comprendre la
notion de totalité
parce que c'est comprendre comment la
totalité si prompt pour se manifester
dans le mond temporel
et dans le monde temporel
alité se manifeste par le moyen de la
dualité cyclique
du positif et du négatif
le positif a besoin d'un négatif qui
l'accueille
latif a besoin d'un positif qui le
remplit
et cette complémentarité des pôles cette
imbrication des opposés dans des cycles
temporel qui roule indéfiniment c'est la
manière dont la totalité se présente à
nos yeux dans le monde temporel
l'éternel retour
il y à un mot technique pour parler de
ça ça s'appelle la palingénésie
hélas palingénésie s'appuie sur l'idée
que les contraires sont liés les uns aux
autres par le cycle dont ils sont les
opposer
donc quand je dis que dans le mond
temporel la totalité se manifeste par la
dualité cyclique
dire que les oppose et définissent les
extrémités d'une totalité et que la roue
du temps mais c'est totalité en
mouvement pour la rendre observable dans
chacune de ces variations
et donc si la corruption est nécessaire
à l'ordre du monde
c'est au sens où la corruption est aussi
nécessaire à la génération que la nuit
les taux jours
ou que la mort l'état la vie
la corruption est nécessaire à l'ordre
du monde
car elle est le versant négatif de la
vie qui a besoin d'aller jusqu'au bout
d'elle-même pour donner naissance à un
nouveau cycle
pour platon le monde sensible le monde
sensible c'est à dire le monde de la
matière
le monde physique dans lequel nous
existons actuellement
ce n'est pas un
réalité
ce n'est pas la vraie réalité
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'expliquer ça
dans de précédents épisodes
l'idée c'est de dire que cette réalité
matérielle n'est qu'une émanation mobile
est temporelle de la réalité éternelle
et invisible qu'est la réalité des
essences
la réalité des idées c'est à dire des
archétypes
et nous mêmes nous sommes des êtres
sensibles de par notre corps
mais nous sommes connectés à cette
réalité d essence
par notre esprit
le nous
c'est à dire
la conscience ce
platon
limitée l'existence à l'existence
matérielle à l'existence physique sur
terre
faire une erreur
c'est confondre l'apparence de la
réalité la dimension sensible
avec les sens de la réalité
la dimension intelligible
alors certes au quotidien dans notre
rapport au monde et aux autres
rien à faire à des entités physique
est ce que les physiciens nomme la
réalité c'est précisément cette réalité
sensible
cette réalité observables et mesurables
donc si vous dites un physicien que la
réalité sensible n'est qu'une version
mobile est temporel d'une autre réalité
il risque de se gratter la tête en se
demandant pourquoi vous lui parlez
pour platon tout ce qui existe dans le
monde physique n'est qu'un exemple
particulier n'est qu'un cas particulier
d'une réalité métaphysique inobservable
sont les essences essence qui ne peuvent
se faire connaître à nous que sous une
forme matérielle autrement dit sous une
forme temporel et corruptible
dans le monde sensible
nous avons affaire à des objets
physiques temporaire
temporaire c'est à dire qui non
seulement ont une fin mais aussi qui ne
cesse d'évoluer
puisqu'il ne cesse de courir à leurs
propres fins
ce qui veut dire une chose très
importante
qui est que dans le monde sensible rien
n'est jamais identique à soi
vous même vous n'êtes plus exactement la
même personne que celle que vous étiez
quand vous allez commencer à écouter cet
épisode
la trentaine de minutes qui séparent
l'instant actuel de l'instant vous avez
lancé l'épisode
c'est une trentaine de minutes pendant
lesquelles
imperceptiblement
vous avez changé
vous n'êtes plus vieux de trente minutes
par rapport au moment où vous avez
commencé à écouter cet épisode
et jusqu'à la fin de cet épisode
vous allez continuer à vieillir
et jusqu'à la fin de cet épisode vous
allez continuer à vieillir
c'est ça le caractère temporel du monde
sensible
l'évolution
l'évolution en permanence
tiers qui se dégrade
inexorablement
et qui fait que votre corps se corrompt
en même temps que votre conscience
expérimente le monde et apprend de son
expérience
mais là où platon vous rassurer c'est
que vous n'êtes pas votre corps
car votre or n'est que le vêtement
devant
chou
et que vous ne vous définissez pas par
vos vêtements
trouverez extravagants venir quelqu'un
par sa tenue vestimentaire
parce qu'on sait que la tenue
vestimentaire
même si elle dit quelque chose de la
personne qui la porte
la personne n'est pas ce qu'elle porte
quand la personne rentre chez elle et
qu'elle retire ses vêtements elle ne
cesse pas pour autant d'exister
tout au plus peut-on dire qu'elle cesse
d'exister aux yeux des autres qui ne la
voit pas sans ses vêtements
mais elle continue d'exister dans
l'intimité de sa nudité
elle est peut-être même davantage elle
même que quand elle porte des vêtements
et qu'elle interagit avec les autres
elle est plus naturelle plus spontané
plus vrai
bien la même façon notre corps entre
l'interface par laquelle nous sommes en
rapport avec les autres dans le monde de
la matière
mais pour platon
notre véritable essence ce n'est pas
notre existence sur le plan sensible
c'est notre existence
le plan
telli gibles
le monde sensible et le monde du devenir
c'est le monde du mouvement de la
génération et de la corruption
de la naissance et de la mort
et pour platon le devenir n'est rien
d'autre qu'une
sion de l'être
lettre est immuable
il est fixe il est éternel
2 rires
c'est la mise en mouvement de l'être
ces lettres qui se manifeste dans la
temporalité et qui en passent par le
cycle pour se faire connaître
la position actuelle de la terre
n'indique pas les sens de la terre
parce qu'en tout état de cause ce que je
viens appelez la position actuelle de la
terre
ja plus la position de la terre
la terre n'a à cesser de se déplacer
pendant que je parler d'elle
son mouvement est indifférent à ce qu'on
dit sur elle
et c'est valable pour tout ce qui existe
dire d'une chose ce qu'elle est celle
arrêtée dans son mouvement
c'est la figer dans le temps
et donc c'est dire seulement un instant
de ce qu'elle est
c'est dire un point de ce qu'elle est
la seule de dire ce qu une chose est
c'est de dire ce que nous dit son cycle
à dire l'intégralité des points quel
parcours
où est ce que je veux en venir
venir au fait que selon platon
on fait erreur à chaque fois que l'on
croit dire lettre d'une chose alors
qu'on le dit en fait qu'un instant de
son devenir
parce que tout ce que je peux dire à
propos d'un objet de sa forme de sa
taille
de son apparence
11 temporaire
ce sont des attributs variable
et la corruption
c'est le phénomène par lequel le devenir
agit sur les choses
et donc la conque
on sait qu'on ne peut rien dire du monde
sensible
ils soient à proprement parler vrai
parce que quelque chose de vrai est
supposé rester vrai
tandis que tout ce que je pourrai dire à
propos du monde matériel
ne sera jamais qu'un instant de la
vérité
et non là même
et remarque
si vous analysez la racine du mot
instant un privatif et ce temps ça veut
dire qui tient ou qui se tient
comme dans le verbe anglais to stand qui
veut dire se tenir
donc un instant
r- allemand
ce qui ne tient pas
ce qui ne dure pas
la conclusion c'est qu'on trouve pas la
verrie la matière
on trouve la vérité en sortant de la
matière
comme le prisonnier ne trouve pas la
vérité dans la caverne
mais en sortant de la caverne
la caverne
c'est le foyer des ombres
c'est le foyer des faux semblants
parce qu'on cherche vérité dans les
ombres les prisonniers ne savaient pas
qu'ils cherchaient la vérité dans ce qui
n'était en réalité qu'un instant de la
vérité
un instant
dégradé de la vérité
quand on dit i la perfection ce monde
tony siens
ça veut dire dans le monde sensible
que des incarnations mobile est
imparfaite de la réalité intelligible
pure dans le cible
rien n'est totalement harmonieux
même les orbites des planètes donne
raison à platon
elles ne sont pas régulières c'est à
dire circulaire
se sont ce
des cercles déformés
et cercles
dégradé
le monde de la mode r et le monde 2
irrité
l'esprit humain lui aime les formes
régulières
il aime la paire fixe de l'abstraction
plate on y voit d'ailleurs une preuve de
la réalité des essences puisque l'esprit
humain est d'attirer par elle
mais dans la été sensible dans notre
monde physique
rien n'est absolument régulier
rien n'est tracé à l'est caire et au
combat
pour faire du magritte un triangle n'est
pas en triangle
c'est la représentation d'un triangle
or représentation est toujours
imparfaite
vous aurez beau vouloir tracer un
triangle parfait vous n'y arriverez pas
parce que l'épaisseur du trait parce que
les irrégularités de votre règle parce
que les rugosités de votre feuille vous
empêcheront toujours de réaliser une
figure parfaite
elle vous en empêche radicalement
on peut viser la perfection
mais on ne peut jamais l'atteindre
pour platon le temps
scellé
est perçue sous l'angle
devenir
et la corruption
c'est la marque du temps qui ne
générer en détruisant ce qui le fait
exister
je cite
quel est le but philosophe
or autant que possible
les distractions que donne le corps gène
l'âme dans sa poursuite de la vérité
pour voir le bon en soi le bo en soi et
toutes les essences le corps est un
obstacle
on ne les saisies qu'avec la pensée
seule et toute pure en sorte qu'il faut
attendre la mort pour que l'âme séparer
de lui puisse atteindre pleinement la
vérité
le philosophe aurait donc tort de
craindre la mort après s'être exercé
toute sa vie à s'abstraire de son corps
c'est à dire en somme après s'être
exercés à mourir
une ancienne tradition veut que les âmes
qui ont quitté ce monde existe dans
l'hadès et que de là elles reviennent
ici
nous étendons notre enquête de l'âme à
tous qui avient nous constatons qu'une
chose naît de son contraire le plus
grand du plus petit et le plus petit du
plus grand le beau du laid et le lait du
bo
le sommeil de la veille et la veille du
sommeil c'est ainsi que la vie n'est de
la mort et la mort de la vie 7
génération est visible tous les jours
nous ne voyons pas l'autre celle qui va
de la mort à la vie
mais à moins que la nature ne soit
boiteuse il faut l'admettre aussi
si en effet les naissances ne
s'équilibre et pas d'un contraire à
l'autre et se faisait uniquement dans un
seul sens d'un contraire à celui qui lui
fait face et jamais inversement tout
finirait par être dans le même état la
génération s'arrêterait et toute ombre
est dans la mort
on pourrait croire au terme de cette
exploration
que platon condamne notre monde
qu'il ne le juge pas
digne de valeur
c'est pas tout il en faut
mais ce serait oublier que pour platon
nous ne sommes pas condamnés
suivre la pente inexorable
de la corruption
nous pouvons l'éviter
comment
on nous dit
et que nous serions notre corps
en nous débarrassant
de l'identification on a la forme
et en a en apercevoir l'éternel
derrière le temporel
nul 2 elle volontairement disait socrate
c'était une manière de signifier que
nous naissons tous inconscient
sont tous
zik de lettres
et l'existence
et le chemin quel on revient
on n'est pas de l'être
pour le retrouver
nul
l'enterrement ça veut dire que
l'ignorance et la cause
si
nous ne faisons
pour faire le mal
nous faisons le mal
parce que nous avons perdu
la direction du bien
et ce qui perturbe l'orientation vers le
bien
c'est l'identification
on a la matière
c
cassions aux apparences temporaire
nous fait perdre du temps
dans notre quête d essence éternelle
apprenez à reconnaître les sens éternel
derrière chaque chose
et vous voilà
rés
de la corruption
apprenez à percer
voile de matière
qui dissimule le vrai à la vue
vous voilà des gens
séjour des éternels
car dès lors qu'on perçoit le vrai
derrière les apparences
soit l'éternité derrière le temps
on perçoit à l'être
derrière le devenir
ouah
vie derrière la mort
je vous remercie
[Musique]